I love this character that you've played
for so many years I mean I think Loki's
been my favorite character if not one of
my favorites if not my favorite um and I
just have to know is this the last time
we'll see you playing Loki I mean I know
you've probably been asked this but are
you done or is there more stories to be
told here's the thing
like in the past I
have
um tied you know say goodbye and we've
you know exchanged notes with Kevin
feige and Lis Di bazito and Victoria
Alonzo and and there have been actually
two I think two times where we all on
all sides we went through the dance of
like thank you so much it's been the
ride of a lifetime you know and they
said come and see us anytime you'll
always be part of the
family and then and there was an
atmosphere of finality about it and then
the phone would ring a year later saying
so we've had an idea and um uh so I I I
think I'm keeping an open heart and an
open mind um what I will say is I'm I
feel
very honored to have concluded season
two in the way that we have I think
there's a kind of
almost poetic or
musical um
uh like the end of a refrain the end of
a
composition
[Music]
um I think it's
uh it contains Echoes and resonances
across my um 14 years of playing the
character 14 years for me 12 years for
the audience but I'm really pleased with
where we ended up I hope it's uh
satisfying for the audience and as for
the rest time will tell yeah I mean I'm
curious you know to hear your take take
on some of these relationships that we'
seen form in this show specifically I
mean I think his Loki's relationship
with Sylvie is such a large part of his
development throughout the seasons
absolutely you know I I think he chose
the past the most resistance in order to
protect her and keep from killing her um
what are your thoughts on that
relationship and that romance between
them if you consider it a
romance they are a mirror to each other
and I think they
they challenge each
other and out of the challenge they grow
together um two characters as they say
the in episode six of season one I think
it's my Loki's line you can't trust and
I can't be trusted these are two
characters who who have become so
accustomed to being alone to surviving
alone
and
the
[Music]
um the
the contrast to trust is betrayal both
characters are expecting betrayal at
every
turn and they have to learn to trust
each other and learn how to trust others
not just each other but Mobius B15 OB
Casey um and to connect to people and
find connections because actually that's
all that life is is
is connecting with each other um and I
think across season two what I loved in
as we developed it um with Eric Martin
the head writer and kathern Blair who
also was on the writing team Kevin
Wright our producer and with Sophia
crucially Sophia de
Martino was finding that basically that
Loki and Sylvie are
in Passionate disagreement about what to
do Sylvia believes that in order for for
free will to thrive in order
for those who have been denied a chance
at life to be given one is for the
TVA not to exist
um and Loki
believes that in a at the same time as
he's trying to redefine his own glorious
purpose I think the TV is trying to
redefine its institutional purpose and
he believes a
TVA as a broken institution can be
reformed and trying to fix what's broken
is worth it it's difficult but it's
worth it and when he's presented with
this impossible
Choice by he who remains he has to go
back to
Sylvie and it's sylv's final words to
him that show him
the middle way so they
are they grow from each other does that
make sense they
um there's that's that's what any
relationship any any meaningful
relationship I think is that
um that you challenge the other person
well not not deliberately but you are
you try to meet the challenge of the
other person and that helps you grow and
Sylvie certainly does that for Loki and
I I hope L does that for Sylvie yeah
definitely I mean speaking about those
important relationships and those
challenges obviously Mobius is another M
big character and big figure in Loki's
life and I think you and Owen have
fantastic chemistry together on screen
and can you talk about bonding these two
characters together especially working
with Owen and then also um what you feel
like the role uh what role mobies has in
Loki's Journey for this
season well first of all I I just so
enjoyed working with Owen Wilson um it's
been it's been really fun and really
fulfilling
and
um his he's just definitive as mobus
he's so uh warm and so intelligent and
so playful and in a way you know Sylvia
is one kind of mirror to Loki and mobus
is another kind of mirror and mobus is
in uced in season one of Loki
as a academic as an analyst as um as
someone who is almost a fan of Loki he s
studied Loki from a distance and is now
getting to see him up close but
crucially Mobius is
detached
from the drama of Loki and I don't think
Loki's ever come into contact with
someone who is able to sit without
judgment in his Pres presence
um everyone else is always part of the
story Odin Thor frer um The Avengers
they're all they're all kind of they all
get emotionally involved in in Loki's
actions and Mobius is is actually kind
of there's a kind of initially
dispassionate
Detachment which allows Loki I think to
feel seen in a way um and
it's a very confronting episode um in
his life but he's on the other side of
it he's given a second chance I don't
think he recognizes it initially but he
is given a second chance
at at life I suppose at at trying to
rethink and redefine what glorious
purpose might mean but then I think Loki
and Sylvie reveal something to movius in
season one they reveal that you know
they all had lives on the timeline that
they they were kidnapped and they were
their memories were
wiped and so Loki has something to teach
Mobius and um they've learned a lot from
each other but they're both
so they're so
um uh Resolute in
their ideas for us I think and ow and I
hope would agree with me the joy of the
scenes with with Loki and Mobis is
they're often paired together trying
to find a solution to a problem they're
trying to solve they're like two
detectives trying to solve a crime and I
find the most enjoyable scenes are often
when they are in Passionate disagreement
about what they're supposed to be doing
and there's a kind of um Loki wants to
do it one way mobus wants to do it
another way and there's underlying kind
of base level of respect but they kind
of bicker and tease each other and
provoke each other and um those are
really fun scenes to play
yeah I mean I definitely you can get
that energy from the screen and I think
that's part of the enjoyment and I just
want to play a little one last thing I
think I
think Mobius is Loki's friend and I
don't think Loki has ever had a friend
before wow that's very sweet and also
kind of
sad so just talking a little bit
hypotheticals you know I know you said
everything the door is open but if there
was a season which I have to ask do you
see a potential for Loki's Continuing
Story you know I know Kevin I was
talking to Kevin right about it and he
said he was actively pitching some ideas
um is there a path that you can see
forward for Loki or are there characters
that you want to see explored more even
if you're not a part of that
story
wow I got a C Kevin rot what's he been
saying what's he been saying let me know
I want to know too yeah um I uh um yeah
I I think you
know what I feel at the moment is
that where we've landed feels
very poetic and
satisfying but at the same
time
um you know who knows what happens who
knows what happens out on
those the branches of reality and and
the the the
Multiverse um though I'm sure there are
conversations happening about about what
what next and um yeah I I
guess I keep an open heart and an open
mind okay well that's a very diplomatic
answer and um I just want to thank you
for speaking with me honestly one of my
favorite shows from uh from Marvel
you've just done a great job and it was
a fantastic finale for me I've also read
a lot of TS Elliott since uh doing these
interviews so I want to thank okay great
yeah well that's just a gift I think I
mean I just find that the four quartets
is just it's just so rewarding it's such
a it's such a extraordinary
text
and because of its abstraction I think
it can mean a many things to many
different people
um and um and and just and thank you so
much for what you've said
I
um I've had the most extraordinary time
playing this character for 14 years the
complexity of the character is endlessly
rewarding um seems to contain so many
multitudes
and I don't take it lightly that the
audience have taken him into their
imaginations and it's a responsibility
that I I'm very honored by um and you
know this is a show about time and how
precious time is and I've given a lot of
my time with great pleasure to this
character and and so to hear you say
that it um that you enjoyed it is um I'm
really grateful to you thank you well
thank you so much and thank you so much
for uh spending time with me here today
course thank so
much